alright guys my name is Russell and I
created the floss and this is that story
alright so it's 2014 I'm living a pretty
normal life I'm like 5 foot 1 I think if
I remember correctly probably less than
a hundred well I wore this huge winter
jacket even in the Sun like every single
day I just wore it and then I had this
bold cut and then I got this haircut and
then I wasn't as lame my øg øg handle I
like cats I thought that they were
majestic it fit my personality so
majestic outlook
yeah not a lot of people know about that
one I only like my close friends so
during the summer of 2014
me and my church we did this little
retreat the other church and all but
there's also like a little dance parties
and stuff like that and at one of those
dance parties I did the floss and they
got a lot of attention and me just being
like a kid I liked the attention I
decided to put it on Instagram because
it was like a fun dance move to do like
comedic and not like meant to be good I
remember having 393 followers and then I
remember I posted on my page I was like
hey guys let's get the 400 followers I
woke up with like 5,000 followers and I
was like we definitely have 400 all of
my friends were texting me and so
they're like wow are you buying
followers right now because you're
gaining pretty fast so I was at my
friend's house right I was sitting in a
chair in the living room and a pair of a
bro I do remember the color the chair
yes I do I was just on my phone I had a
green iPhone 5c at the time and then I
look at the top of my screen that says
you were tagged in a post so I clicked
on the notification I looked at the
amount of followers that that person had
and they had like 750 K I was like oh my
gosh I just got reposted by this cage
and he tagged me and then I don't know
oh yeah oh I do remember I do remember
how he found me I remember how he found
me okay when I posted that dance video
on my page somebody commented hashtag
don't stop white people 2k14 and then
when he found that hashtag he was like
hey this kid's got some moves I just
started getting thousands out
thousands of followers I was like oh my
god yo yo yo yo look look look and then
after that I went home I told my mom I
was really excited about it at first I
didn't know what was gonna happen before
that I had my notifications on when I
started getting to around 50k and like I
would charge my phone and wake up and
have a whole list of Instagram
notifications and then eventually I just
turned them off okay so one day Rihanna
yes the Rihanna
bad girl RiRi on Instagram she posts the
one on my video the next day at school
it was pretty hectic everybody started
coming up to me like whoa Rihanna has
posted you how at that point I gained
like 3 K followers in a day the
following May we got an email from Katy
Perry talking about some hey I wanted to
join me anything else that's not true
I thought it was just like somebody
trolling or something like that but then
we went through the paperwork we signed
a contract you know whoa this is
actually happening I was on the plane
with my mom going to New York and then
we went to the hotel and then the next
day it was the actual performance they
walked me to the back of the stage
before going on and then like I was
texting all my friends was like bro you
better be watching this right now and I
was like really scared because there was
like 13 million people watching live and
you can't really mess up on live TV and
go back from that
I mean I didn't mess it up so the song
ended and then I went off stage I was
like whoa that actually just happened I
would say that the biggest turning point
was SNL for sure because I remember like
the day after I had so many interviews
and magazines to do I did not realize
that it would go as big as it did but
I'm glad I did because I can travel a
lot now and there's this one time I went
to the ESPYs in our leg but I didn't
have tickets to get in so I was just
kind of standing outside and then here
comes O'Dell everybody started as
swarming him and I was like hey hey
Odell and I'm pretty sure he knows me
because he got me in he just grabbed my
arm and pulled me in he gave me a little
slap on the chest and I kind of got
winded who have I met I got a list
uh sure little boy Lele pons that took
me forever to say yeah I don't really
see myself as a celebrity I go out in
public with my friends all the time you
will see me at the mall you will see me
go bowling and you will see me I
McDonald's I don't see myself at the
backpack kid much at all but I mean like
I know I have to at some times like when
I'm in a video or something like that
I've been riding this philosophy for a
while well I got to start branching out
it makes me feel like I'm being caged
into the dance like people only know me
for the flaws and I'm more than just
that dancing is not just my thing I can
do other things people are just gonna
get bored of it and then I'm just gonna
start losing followers and falling off
and I don't want that to happen music
was something I've been wanting to do
for a little while now and so I dropped
a single-car trip on boat with swag
Hollywood and then that's starting to do
pretty good and then there's gonna be an
EP coming after
if I were to give any advice to anybody
it's all about having fun with it you
can't have fun with it then it's not
worth doing and that's where I am now
see everybody on the Internet
[Music]